I think bloggers or bloggers and there
are good ones in there,
allows you once,
you know,
Andrew Sullivan is a really good
blocker.
He has four or five issues he's
passionate about.
He has a couple of good webby ideas like
readers sending in pictures out their
windows.
Um,
um,
he's good at it.
There are political blogs that are good
at it.
There are specialty blogs that are good
Um,
are there a lot of bloggers who are
doing the,
you and I understand to be the
conventional,
uh,
reporting,
um,
work of a Bob Woodward or a Seymour
Hersh or Jane Mayer,
whatever.
Not a lot.
No.
That's expensive.
Consuming a and it's not blogging.
You can't do it five,
six times a day.
On the other hand,
I'm Joshua and Mika Marshall does a very
good job by continually linking to
things that he thinks that you should be
as obsessed with as he is and what
you're reading with him as a kind of.
You're staying with a certain political
sensibility.
It's interesting.
So to me the question is not,
are they journalists,
journalists?
It's just obviously a new form,
a different form,
and there are good ones and bad ones.